brought to you by far cry primal rise
above extinction in stores februari 23rd
it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and it's also
Valentine's Day and you should spend as
much time with your loved ones as you
can because this week we get street
fighter 5 first up street fighter 5
you're getting the x gauge back that was
introduced back in Street Fighter 3 it
builds as the player lands tax it can be
used either to power up special moves or
perform those super combos known as
critical arts however focus attacks have
been removed new to this game is the B
gauge which builds as a player is
receiving attacks and it adds three new
techniques there's the skills V
reversals and V triggers additionally
the stun meter which has always been
around since Street Fighter 3 it's now
visible under the health bar in the game
you get 16 characters at launch 12
you'll remember but for that are new get
your head you can on on the 16th xbox
one owners you felt a little left out of
the soccer game with rocket-powered
battle cars can rest easy rocket League
is now on xbox one and to make up for
lost time they've also given us the
gears of war armadillo and halo stickers
they still love you you and your friends
can enjoy hours and hours of online
matches proving your driving skills and
team cohesion score says it all so go
out there and be somebody up your game
on the seventeenth remember when PT was
cancelled and everyone was bummed out
well a lot of people compared that game
to dis layers of fear and coming out of
early access this week you're in a
creepy house learning about a painter
who fell from grace trying to reclaim
his old glory with a masterful painting
but comments like he went insane
some creepy [ __ ] happened I hope you
like dolls this comes out on the 16th
hey do you like Tron visuals consider an
endless runner with that style this
games got over 30 levels customizable
and upgradable characters and an EDM
soundtrack to boot game features three
modes focused on identity disc combat
light cycle driving and an endless
stream variety that's out on pc ps4 and
xbox one on the 16th 3ds owners are
happy this week because Fire Emblem is
coming out but what you get depends on
what you ordered this tactical RPG puts
you on one side of two opposing factions
but you get a different storyline
centered around the same characters in
three different versions birthright and
conquest our physical releases and
revelation as downloadable content
conquests limits your resources so it's
a little bit more difficult whereas
birthright is a bit more newbie friendly
and focuses on making the babies unless
you've already pre-ordered you'll have
to wait for revelations until March 10th
birthright and conquest are yours on the
19th finally if you want to be
surrounded by a bunch of creature
straight from hell you should check out
devil daggers you're basically stuck on
a platform with a bunch of skeletons and
centipedes of death that endlessly come
after you but you have your dagger
fingers and a mean dash jump good luck
that's out on the 18th so that's it for
this week remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and
they're subject to change let me know
where is stood in picking up and we'll
see you again next week